welcome to the iron lords podcast
all right and we are live more content
they don't hear iowa
with the amazing devs who are these fine
ladies in the room today
i'm counting
and i'm charizard i'm production
director at interior nights
upgraded
let's talk about as does false lord's
got a chance just to see some behind the
scenes action of this amazing game very
unique narrative art style for those who
don't know in the realm tell everybody
everyone about pasta forms
so asphalt is a interactive story you
can play with people you love it's a
compelling mature story
super approachable you can play with up
to eight players online locally so on
your couch with your partner for example
after the kids are in bed or your
friends at dinner or maybe your best
friend who lives on the other side of
the country awesome awesome so one thing
we know is right off the bat i would say
is this unique narrative of this art
style yes you know and the way you tell
to people about like what was the
inspirations behind that
so the inspiration behind the art style
was really to make um so that was unique
to really be tailored to this type of
storytelling and we wanted to capture
the full emotions all those nuances that
we express as humans we wanted those to
be in the game so that you never really
break you never break that connection
that the player has to all of the
characters on screen
i think it does a really good job at
doing that because when you're playing a
game that you're looking at polygons or
graphics and things like that there's
always moments where it's not cinematic
whereas
very mundane things that happen during
game play and then you have a cinematic
moment that sort of engages you
emotionally here you're always engaged
emotionally because your caption like
you said the perfect facial expressions
the moment that something happens and
everything sort of crescendos at the
same time whether it be the look on the
character space the music the sound
effects that are happening it's all sort
of one perfect portrait of every single
thing that's happening in the game at
every single moment and that's very cool
because gameplay
doesn't even see that very often i agree
i think i think for me what really
resonated was um you know by that art
style i felt it was very expressive
in the multicapture emotion as well and
i wanted to talk about it looks like as
dust was going to talk about some deeper
subject matters yeah you know so is am i
right there is are we going into places
where we're going to make players
uncomfortable with decisions they may
make based on these things um i wouldn't
say uncomfortable hopefully um but it's
we do broach like mature and sometimes
possibly like dark things but you know
all of us in our lives have gone through
like struggles and difficult moments
um so it's to reflect that but it's also
uplifting moments you know it's really
about the relationships you have with
your family and how you grow and change
and how you overcome some trauma you
might have in the past so it's it's
really topics that could have happened
to any of us you know are you gonna be
staying married with your wife but also
you make big decisions about which
hostage is gonna be taken out of the
hotel to safety so it's that mix of
big and smaller decisions but all have
an impact on the character's fate and
their state of mind so speaking which
let's just talk timeline like set place
for like 1998 where where we where is
this going at the motel for those who
don't know
yeah yeah absolutely
so the game is set in 1990 starts in
1998 in arizona in the middle of the
desert in a small town called called
true rock and we spend time in this
motel where the hostage situation takes
place but after a few episodes it
expands across multiple states in the us
uh because it becomes like a chase you
follow a character is trying to escape
to canada so you you will like see a lot
of different locations and atmosphere in
this like it's really a wide scoping
story and multiple years as well right
and multiple years very good points
i heard you mentioned that earlier and i
said wow okay so this is going to be
this
truly sort of epic hispanic story yeah
exactly you get to really shape these
characters with the decisions that you
make and shape their stories and their
lives like you say over decades so you
see the impact of your choices come out
in their future
that's pretty cool that's fantastic so
tell us a little bit about the gameplay
right because i think
from what everyone is seeing you see
sort of everything seems cinematic they
don't really show how the game plays out
and we got to see a little bit of that
so can you explain exactly how the game
is played
it's essentially
decision making throughout so you see a
beautiful story happen and on screen and
every 20 seconds also you make a
decision and it's very very approachable
and mean
so you can play with controller or a
mobile app free mobile app on your phone
and use your phone as a controller
and you simply move a cursor
everyone has a cursor who plays with you
and you make decisions like it's like
it's kind of rooting and the one um the
choice that gets the most votes
i think that was the thing that actually
excited me about the game because
i remember obviously when you first
announced the game we first saw it it
was in 2020 it was right the first one
okay it looks like a very cool
interesting game but i'm thinking of it
like a traditional telltale type game
one player you get into this immersion
story but those are games i like don't
get me wrong but what i when you read
when it came out the xbox showcase and i
heard multiplayer component i'm not
interested how is that going to work and
getting a chance to see it behind the
scenes one thing that really really
resonated with me was the the
decision-making process
the break and then this override thing
yeah and that is what you mean
so tell us about that override mechanic
for those of you
so each of us like each of the players
have a cursor so they should essentially
have a voice it's like they're a voice
in the character's head and each of us
have different opinions and ideas so if
when you feel really strongly about a
choice and you don't agree with the
majority in the room in your team
you can override which is essentially
like a takeover of the boat
and everybody's cursors are frozen but
you can move your yours
and make your decision but you do have
to be careful because like i can
override your overlap
and that's what happens right when your
overrides run out because
everybody has a limited amount of
override so then what happens at that
point well no one can override anymore
but the cool thing so we set a limited
number of overrides per chapter
but if you don't like it you can go in
them settings in the menu and change
that amount
i was thinking about
the obviously you have the hardcore
gamer who's going to love
narrative-based choices and these great
decisions and these branching paths
right but then i'm thinking about like
someone like my mom or someone who is
not the traditional gamer and what's
cool i feel is the phone component and
xcloud component because you can get
more people involved in these type of
decisions so tell us about that give us
some twitch integration integration all
kinds of crossbars like gameplay is
essentially super scalable because it's
like one player one cursor one vote
right so going on twitch makes perfect
sense like the host
runs the game and then the audience
votes for different decisions and it's
essentially the same
kind of atmosphere uh as playing the
paint office in the same room
so it's like really really scalable
game design
very skilled i thought i'm sorry yeah i
was just gonna say i think your point
about
your mum could play is really strong
because this is the game i think my
non-gamer friends are going to pick up
and they're going to be happy to play
with me
because they have a phone so it's really
simple they don't even need to have the
game in the room with me there
and like you guys said like it's
it's very engaging because it is sort of
that amalgam of games but like prestige
television where you're like a great
television show or breaking bad where
you have you know you you have these
characters that are going to grow and
evolve and but the thing is you have
agency in that and that's that's
when it comes to games that's what it is
the agency you have even if it's not you
know a person but to slash something or
whatever the fact that you can
kind of mold where their life goes in
this story is
i think to me is the that's the most
powerful the other one it comes to this
type of game right because traditionally
you look like i said we've talked about
heavy rain indigo prophecy and you take
the story places but you're kind of
controlling the third person character
here yeah it is
it's just like i'm looking at the
characters one of the characters just
eyes and his eyes say everything about
the situation that's happening and
sometimes you miss that in a game that's
you know about polygons and stuff like
that so
yeah this is i i've i had a great time
with 20 minutes
oh yeah absolutely i mean one thing is
like i said outside the expressive you
know way the characters are drawing
things like that you know it really
showed to me how much writing is
necessary for all the branching choices
so what i wanted to ask is from a
development standpoint how long has it
asked us to forbidden development and
then like i think about the game that
mass effect yes and you think about okay
if you do this then it can branch this
way
like
how tedious is that as that must be a
challenge as a studio to do that much
writing and that much choice bridge yes
yeah
so
first question
we've been
beginning the development like end of
2017
for me started like a few years before
that but like with the team we started
end of so that's four years and a half
or so
which is can be seen as a long time but
it's actually a big game and it was our
first game as a studio so you've got
loads to figure out like the tools
you know
studio works and we highlighted teaming
like we created all the development
processes and all of that to really
support the script and the story because
like that is number one i'd say you know
that's part of the ethos of the whole
studio telling interactive stories
so everything started like it starts
with we started with the design right
because the way you experience the story
is kind of as important as what the
story is about it goes in hand really
but um we wrote the story we got a team
of
two full-time writers at some point it
was free
and we wrote 1200 pages of script wow
but actually that's more than that
because we iterate so many times
that's the final script is 1200 pages
right at least we got like probably
three times that it's like a
tv series uh writer's room so we all go
we've got like the we break down the
season like all the six chapters
by blogs and then
we do outlines and script versions and
rewrites and
read table reads with the team it's
great moments usually when we do that
yeah
it's so much fun and then user testing
you know and as you go and
it's a constant it's not like we do the
script and then we make it right we keep
uh iterating as we are making the game
because we test the story the gameplay
is the story really so you make sure
everything hits right and that the the
decision-making is like clear for the
players because sometimes you intend
something and it doesn't come across the
right way so players are could be
surprised by a decision they make and
they expect something else so we
fine-tune that all the way through
i have to say every you talk about the
length of the script and just like how
big a challenge you know that is even in
film tv well
but then when you're making a game every
word on that script
involves hours of dev teamwork too so
yeah this is a big you know big spin
game
so when you guys when you write the
script and then you just so how is it
acted out is it act do you have the
actors
what they act out and and you record is
that the audio or is the audio separate
and you do that as a booth thing
so we do we do live-action shoots but we
don't capture audio or shoots because um
then
for the quality of sound et cetera and
sometimes we have different actors we do
the voice then we do the visual
performance
um because you know maybe you want to
elaborate on that yeah we want to
i mean
also because you know the way it's being
acted out it's a branching storyline
right so it's not just like one linear
story that you just sort of capture in
one go so to really um do justice to
that it's much better to record the
audio afterwards but you know with the
whole
the casting of the live performance
actors and the voice over actors we
wanted to keep it really authentic
in in the way it comes across on the
screen and we wanted to be very
authentic in our casting of actually who
gets to do that so we chose people with
lived experience of those ethnicities
and you know those ages so that all
really contributes to the whole
story being put together and that nuance
coming across yeah i thought that that
definitely showed and the two things for
me that really resonated was the the
amount of choice
per like every 20 seconds there was yeah
there's a chance yeah you're engaged
like there's no sitting back and just
watch a story yeah and when you think
about the different sort of emotions
that you choice each choice would sort
of branch you off into you you talk
about you know 1200 pages of script yeah
because you know they were often at
least a few times they were sort of
comedic yes yes sarcastic choices that
hopefully would bring down the tension
or something like that um
yeah i just think
to see that and to see how that sort of
affects and getting able to go back to
the expressions on the face and things
of that nature that was that is so
impressive because again when you look
at it it's
outwardly it's like this is this is a
pretty simple game but when you think
that when you see in action in motion
one of the things that's super
impressive to me is when you showed us
afterwards the branches are about to say
yeah yeah when we get to the end of the
of the chapter it's
it shows every everybody's sort of
virtue rating and sort of based on the
actions that they all sort of uh
had during that chapter so i had to
balance them yeah
i was virtuous
how did you guys come to the idea of
doing that as a sort of like kind of
everybody taking a moment to reflect on
the choices
you know look at it you know their
partner
hey man
i mean like for me again like it's it's
the reason why we're doing this i think
it's just adds an
extra interesting
layer to this type of experiences where
the game feedbacks to you
what
the gamers learn about you but it's not
like the game is
i mean it's like because it's it's
important sometimes we make decisions
and stuff and we never pose and reflect
on
or rarely pose and reflect on what's
important for us in life and when you're
like yeah okay honor family
love like really my core fundamental
principles i think it's it's just so
cool to see that and triggers
interesting conversations as well it's
fun
and i think it triggers them with people
who normally wouldn't have those
conversations because this in a way
simplifies it it says okay i look at the
decision i made it gives you an abc
choice or whatever and then yeah at the
end it's like okay you're this right but
it's not that simple but it does it
starts conversation
and you the more you play you the more
you discover like each chapter has a set
of values and threats depending on the
you know all the choices options so the
more you play anymore you build your
kind of insight profiles and if you go
into the menu afterwards you can see
your top three values your top three
trades and your face times so you're not
like it's not monolithic it's like the
more you play the more you discover very
cool very cool as you can see it's
yourself as a studio now that you know
you're getting closer and
obviously we saw the game back then we
see it now
what did it feel like to be like
on the xbox but that's the showcase
you're getting showcased again and
something that you know it's coming out
and people are generating as a student
how did that feel
do you want to speak you speak about how
you felt yeah yeah
yeah i mean surreal like that first i
was like super honored to be on the
stage
and it's so great honestly i'm super
happy to be able to present
the game with in our own words
it's quite cool
and it's the rest of it is real
okay well we we watched the showcase
with um we were here like in this
microsoft space but we also had the team
on zoom yeah and so we had the whole
team they were in the uk we're in the us
and we invited the actors along who
played the characters in the game
and
um you know we had our counterparts at
microsoft too so that was really special
for me it felt like everybody in the
same space like watching this moment
together it's been four and a half years
we couldn't talk about the release date
yeah we couldn't talk about the
multiplier we couldn't talk about all
these really unique features that we put
in there and now we can and how much
work was it just to get you know the
trailer for the show because uh people
talk about how hard it is to get
anything ready for just a big
presentation like that and was it was it
kind of in the natural process of your
work or was it something you had to sort
of handle aside
i mean the game is essentially finished
so like we had loads of moments of the
game that could be captured and edited
for trailers so it wasn't
this time around
obviously as gamers hardcore gamers you
always talk you talk about um
you know play time right how long how
long we're going to spend in this game
and obviously as a narrative-based game
people talk about the branching paths
how many different branching paths how
many endings so can you talk a little
bit about that like what can we expect
in terms of how many times we can play
through this and see totally different
things yeah
yeah i'm sorry i don't know it's cool
it's good absolutely we got six chapters
each chapter is an hour play through
so if you play the game from start to
finish
uh it's going to be six hours
but there's many many more content and
branches so you can play and replay
in my head i don't know if it's gonna
happen like that i see people playing
solo
and then play again
with people they love yes so that's your
experience different branches and the
mere fact of playing with different
people
turns the experience into something else
like it's a different atmosphere you've
got to have different talking points
so it's very very incredible from that
point and in terms of my of endings it
doesn't i don't know
which characters well because it's
it's quite modular so each character has
their own set of fates
and and you have agency on almost all of
those so depending what you do
you can have very very different
combinations
i think for me what makes it really
special and the reason why i would play
with different people and still have a
unique experience it's because you learn
about the people that you're playing
with and you learn about yourself at the
same time so like harry and i mean how
many times have we played
the same chapters together and there are
still huge
differences charlie likes to murder
again just i think you really guys
really have something special
our style is fantastic you know it
definitely um
is tackling a lot of cool stories
multiple characters i think it's great
that it's multi-player right and then on
top of that we've got the xcloud thing
we've got the game pass thing so it's so
exciting getting a whole group more
people you know we're getting close to
lunch you know for the people what do
you want to tell people again as you get
close to release as much as they can
about asthma falls
well i would love them to experience a
new type of story very mature compelling
with people they love
whether their game is or not everyone
can jump in and enjoy as those possible
closing
i tell you
i
for a long time i've been waiting for
ken levine's next game because he's had
he's had this this thing about narrative
legos right yeah creating a narrative
that just branches and it goes and all
these different
directions that it feels very natural
i'm gonna be honest when i saw this and
saw the branching pass at the end
specifically you tell me you have so
many endings
you might have beaten them to the
position
this i'm so excited about this game
because again it when you see it out
it's oh it's a narrative it's great okay
have a great story
everything we saw today
everything about how you interact with
it the multiplayer what that creates in
a in a personalized settings what that
can
create in an online setting
it makes this um so much more exciting
um so i think you have something very
special
an absolute pleasure the developers here
as does falls again release date for
those who do
19th of july 19th of july we're getting
close getting closer
as dust falls an absolute pleasure
[Music]
you